I'm with two Bernie delegates and one
super delegate and they listened to
President Obama last night and that's
what it took for them to switch and be
with her what was the magical moment
well the president touched on all the
right things and he really tapped into
the frustration that everybody feels and
he said to Bernie people were right and
we need that energy we need to engage
those people we need those young
energetic voters to be involved and they
gotta push Hillary on the issues and he
was right about that as well Oh her
account holder account the fact that he
recognized that is important what were
you gonna do like up until that feature
though well personally I was waiting for
instruction from senator Sanders and how
we will take the political movement but
when a president obama compared to feel
the Bern movement are kind of to his the
no way that this is what got me over the
top and I need you to do the same thing
this time around that kind of let me
know okay well this is a different ball
game let's get this guy yes absolutely
yes or no ken Hillary Clinton get down
with a political revolution balls in her
court she can but she got to work for I
said yes or no we're gonna get her down
that's our job we'll get it down well
like he said of balls in her court she
has to reach out she's got a lot of work
to do